okay people joining this livestream this
is a tentacle of our neural network
system relevant for the release of
version 1204 n't operator a
generalization of the net fold operator
um and let's try to understand what
know--this is can you get me again yes
I'm set to set the scene a little bit
should I do that quickie
yes sure um so to set the scene a little
bit one of the things that's going to be
happening in 12 which is I think super
important for this for the framework is
net function and that is a way of of
basically writing code that implements
the noise excuse me have we reviewed net
function it's not it's not it's not for
12 so it's oppose 12 first 12 oh I mean
sorry I meant to say post 12 okay
yeah so this is got to use the compiler
and things yeah yeah among other things
so what did we buy among other things
what else is it using of the compiler
well it's the program it's solving is
not is not really solved by the compiler
so I think compilers more thing for
custom layers function functional layer
net function layer for example which is
similar to that function but it's net
functions it's more way of building a
network by symbolically running code
which is what modern frameworks it's a
move that almost all the modern
frameworks are making towards it's
called defined by run rather than then
sort of defined by because in
constructing different layers and
plugging them together lavoris lis
okay so um but so it's a Ramos image
hold on
just explain this to me for a second
so I don't
what this is just a repeat of net graph
isn't it it's an alternative a superior
alternative to net graph yes so instead
the kind of net graph represents the
static single assignment form or a
program and writing that program in
silico single assignment form is quite
tedious and hard for humans to do so net
function is sort of the high level
version of that it's really different
it's exactly the same information of it
it's a bunch of layers connected in a
graph for the most part yes that's true
so what else is it there are some things
that you would do so take higher-order
layers like mapping or folding so in
cases like this or even structural
operations like flattening reshaping
it's kind of thing yep the way that you
kind of want to express those in a net
function world is just by using the
mathematical functions themselves so
just ordinary flat an ordinary array we
shape ordinary plus you don't to use you
know plus layer reshape layer those kind
of layers don't really have a reason to
exist in the world of net function yeah
I remember saying that long ago when we
were introducing those layers it's like
when we have us why do we have these
layers but I think
what you're thinking about there is
there are Wolfram language functions
that operate on lists and in some sense
you know just like there's a notion of
list ability there's also a version of
network ability in some sense yeah yes
and it's not even a very abstract sense
there's there's there's just not analogs
but exact parallels so okay but but so
but certain functions like if I say you
know Rea I function of a layer which is
common element wise you know function
application I mean okay so there are
functions that are there the element
wise which are in fact the listable
functions probably and there are
functions that are more like array
flattened would be another or block map
those will be two examples of functions
that one could imagine in a
convolutional neural net e-type way
wanting to apply yes exactly so we want
more and more of the language to just
sort of define a network as easily as
you would as you would run it on
ordinary lists so they do need to be in
a special context because in a network
only some things are differentiable and
that's you know this is a little bubble
of sort of differentiable operations
that when you know that we can limit I
mean I understand that that that claim
but what is you know isn't it the case
that eventually everything should be
differentiable
some things like random choice will
never be differentiable okay my claim
will be any function with a
deterministic output is differentiable
in principle
well if it isn't it's just an
implementation detail right now you may
be right about that I'll have to think
very carefully about that me okay so let
me give an example of one which where I
might be wrong okay so something like
GCD is GCD differentiable an integer
function well I mean there's a sort of
technicality here which is that as long
as it can be built out of primitives
that are differentiable then the entire
thing is differentiable even if it makes
choices that are not themselves you know
smoothing sort of continuous choices by
even random choices is differentiable
because the piece that it selects out
you know the gradient can be injected
back into the original list from which
it's selected a piece while the throat
specifically something like GCD is it
the case that that an integer operation
like that that you can see a path to how
that can be differentiable
I think what's up yes okay I think it
probably is I mean it might yeah
so ultimately what you're saying is that
one can imagine one just has a piece of
Wolfram language code
and
that code you know it might operate on
an image for example
and I mean I don't even know what it
looks like I mean like like for example
let's take you to you take the image
Island fire okay and you take the
forward execution of the image
identifier what is that in terms of
ordinary code
you understand my question yes I mean
that that's very much not I mean the
convolution parts those are things that
they're not calls to miss convolve or
whatever our mathematical function is
called and what are they what are they
they are their own things like an
confidence in the walls kind of you know
independently of both if I understand
yourself what you've got here so just so
I understand a convolution layer is like
a block map is that true
yes does block back overlap the blocks
oh yes yes it does I mean like a
cellular automaton
I mean convolution layers are like
continuous selling automata oh well
that's non overlapping okay with offset
DS I can overlap the blocks so it'll
involve that and it'll involve sort of
any algebra basically just dot I think
the convolution layer for that yeah so
that the actual content of the
convulsant it like lists convolve except
it isn't quite yeah
but so my question is when we look at
these functions right as you go towards
a world in which these are just ordinary
functions right you know I would think
[Music]
you know I don't know even what this
does but let's say we have from you know
let's try and get it okay
grand so if I say something like I don't
know what this does I don't know whether
we can do this , for for example does
that work
hmm okay I understand that statement
that but anyway well okay that didn't do
what I expected
um okay
by the way a question which I also would
like to know the answer to are we um
automatic differentiation Auto grad or
whatever it is
um are we using the MX net layer or or
are we intended to implement our own
and that is a vast project that would
would would be a sort of more
company-wide thing because it took a
touch and just large large parts of of
the existing language precisely because
so much our language is mathematical I
don't think it's quite right for us for
the moment I think there's some very
nice things you can do with that but
it's so far away from the existing
framework that well you know saying
differentiy ability of I mean most thing
the language is not by its nature you
know it's not set up to be
differentiable
I mean we'll explain what your statement
to me so so auto water grade refers to a
specific kind of technology and so it
involves tracking the evaluation of you
know various functions often the any
algebra
time on inputs on inputs and as you
combine those raise and evaluate
functions on them they could be
piecewise functions and there could be
element-wise functions like sine rampu
there could be dot whether it could be
adding two arrays together
you're also recording a little sort of
graph of how you got to the current
computations so that later on you can do
back prop and this technology is being
done in various modern frameworks it's
it is nice it means that by the time
you've got an answer you've also got a
recipe for how to produce gradients back
to the original ingredients of that
answer that's it's kind of what's net
function will achieve in a different way
and what what autograph does is it does
it live so why we're not in a position
to do that why are we not in a position
to say you know sort of differentially
evaluate of an expression because we
certainly know in our sort of and we we
better than you know I mean we have a
symbolic trace of what happened we don't
happen to keep it a lot around for very
long but I mean if we said
differentiable a evaluate bad name of
exper right that would give a
um
um you know that that gives the result
and the essentially evaluation graph
right there's actually nothing I mean
okay this this reminds me a lot of what
we're doing in for example automated
theorem proving when we generate a list
of things that you can evaluate to get
you know to reprove the theorem so to
speak so similarly here this is some
digested evaluation chain that you can
also you know go back and differentiate
or back propagate through
yes no there's nothing preventing this
from existent but it's just this is a
lot of work and it's actually don't
speak it so much more because I think it
just plugs into the evaluator we already
know this we already have this
information no because there's a library
of so for that for that tape that you're
recording to be to be useful it has to
be that graph has to correspond to
things for which you have the rules for
how to do that and that reminds a
translation between the semantics of our
language and the semantics of whatever
back-end is doing the actual backdrop
for you okay well that's different thing
right but I mean the point is for every
I mean obviously yeah we don't I mean
the back propagate backpropagation it's
not exactly a complicated operation once
you know what to do on a given for a
given operator I mean we don't want to
write a node unit snitch we can't that's
not that's a that's a bad idea
I mean it it does make sense for us to
focus on the things that we can that we
can add value to you and I understand
yeah I understand but
well I'm not thrilled with what you're
telling me here I mean basically you
know there's a right way to do it which
is not what we're doing we're doing
something which is halfway between what
we're doing now and another way of doing
it it's what you basically say
I mean I guess like I would say this I
would say that net function has many of
the it is pretty similar to
differentially evaluate like I can
articulate what the differences are
yeah and I don't think what we lose from
what dead function is is very much
really
so an in fact net function can
transparently be upgraded to the full
differentially evaluate that you imagine
for the future
so it is a stepping stone that can
become a bridge so to speak so long long
ago telling when we were first talking
about the way that neuron that
functionality would work okay maybe four
or five years ago now um more than that
perhaps um
you
you know we had been talking about these
these ways to combine functions and it
was related also to generalizing sort of
Combinator like ways of combining
functions right because essentially when
you're talking about your graph your
graph is
couldn't principle represented by
Combinator type functions yes yes I
actually remember that conversation well
we started designing various Combinator
forms of writing programs like this yes
so this I think that that's a dead end
and and the reason is that people don't
write they don't think like that they
think in terms of programs where you
name variables that store results and
then you use them in new computations
and you get you eventually compile that
to something that looks like an ED graph
but you don't handwrite and that it is
literally SSA form you don't unwrap that
SSA
no one does that it's very tedious to do
and I think the number one thing is to
get away from that and towards a thing
that looks like natural code
well I'm sorry you say they don't write
what SK Combinator type stuff or what
they don't write SSA so they don't
experiment ok which is which is
basically register it's where you've
like allocated registers to store all
the results and you refer to previous
but I mean that's what net growth
currently is and it's very very tedious
and ok so ok
then there's imperative programming then
there's functional programming but you
know storing variables you know assign
it giving names to things and storing
them away is not a functional
programming story
what does there's not much of a
difference um map is very common I mean
that happens intensive flow even if
President
I mean Python can be very fun functional
and pint which certainly is right so you
can you you can have all the nice
goodies from function a question is the
question is whether the core of the
system is something that's all about
naming variables which is what we seem
to have with all of our named layers and
named ports and all that kind of thing
whether it's more like functional
programming and whether in fact the
types of you know networks that turn out
to be useful are well represented using
functional programming um I think that's
a false economy explain why
um the naming is not so much that you
changing variables in a mutable the way
that you like affarin
imperative style of programming it's not
really about that it's just naming a
temporary results so that you can use it
in two places are great crazy
accommodators give an alternative where
you don't have to name anything but they
just do just use nabob because you can't
read anything easily
it is funny there'll be a hundred years
old next year
no you're after next and and really it
seems like nobody's understood them in
100 years so maybe it's just not humans
aren't well well you know combinators
aren't a good match for humans for
simple things they can be quite elegant
but as soon as you've got anything
complicated going on and you sort of
need to to label the different pieces
and I think that that's the only sense
that I use the word variables I don't
mean muted ly changing anything okay but
but so fine but so what does that relate
then so net function as you've proposed
it has
some weird list of sequence of layers
type thing which I don't really
understand at all I know it doesn't
really know what this is honestly I
think this is so old I'm not I can't
vouch for it
well it's 2015 this is from 2015 mmm it
might represent net function layer
honestly that could be it
yeah okay all right okay well so you've
got a different thing in mind for that
okay let's go back to your net right on
top right time we meant you know
recording my deep suspicion of this
okay so the reason I brought up net
function and it was quite a detour but
there is important because it I wanted
to emphasize that there's this kind of
migration we're making which is for all
the sort of structural operations we
really don't want to have we don't want
to duplicate the language we wanted to
just have the language be a good
language to define networks where you
call flexin you know what we planned
many many years ago yes okay so actually
to be fair we knew that that was that
was where we thought we would go but we
decided in order to pander to the
existing frameworks and the things that
could be efficiently implemented we will
basically define this more block diagram
machine code e type thing so we kind of
knew that we were okay but go ahead I
think that I think you're right in the
history of that and it's also like we've
try to functioning normally to achromat
for three years because we did eat
somewhat hacky thing first right yes and
and we we in a position that has
deprecated all of those structural
layers and have the language be the way
that you the ordinary language be the
way that I am but this is such a layer
is it not um no the operators are
different so let me explain that for a
moment if you if you think about net map
operator what I want you to imagine is
on one hand what you do today which is
take a subnetwork
and put it into net map operator and
then apply that to an input and what you
will do in the in the net function
future which is to just simply map so
net map operator is the pre net function
version of map
you
has a certain lack of examples here
yeah I'm sure we can always add more
documentation um so at that point made I
mean I'm not sure I fully understood
that point so net map operator
represents a net image net is mapped
over a sequence of inputs to give a
sequence of outputs okay right so this
is just mad this is when we have net
function you would never bother to make
a net map operator you would simply just
map whatever NIT is could be a
subnetwork could just be flatten right
it doesn't even have to be a network it
can be that function you just map it
over one of your one of your tensor when
your tensor results well it's not
obvious I mean what level you're mapping
at and the tensor at the rotor atella
there's a bunch of hair isn't there yes
I mean we'll support multiple layers and
in fact the new net map thread operator
which we designed last time would again
just be map thread then this layer is
it's a bubble of marriage function this
exists in the present and I would
right what is net recurrent operator so
here's the thing net fold operator is
kind of pretending to be the same thing
it was pretending to be fold before when
it function existed okay
but it's not it's really not and the way
that we would naturally generalize it
doesn't have anything to do with how
fold works and so that's why I mean we
can we don't have to name a net
recurrent operator but I do think that
this is not net fold operator we're not
just going to add features to an eight
fold operator because there would be no
way to express it inside net function as
an ordinary language function you know
like it's not fold so that's that's
today's puzzle is what is this net
recurrent operator
what is it the operator form of I mean
you know I mean what is it the pre net
function form of that we will eventually
yeah what is it I don't know what it
does so what does it do um so it does
what net fault does in a decimal things
to and the fact that you're naming this
fold is just like super confusing yeah
this this documentation is literally
cloned from fold so that should be
called something else recur or something
what is the difference okay so what you
have here what do you mean by folded
over its inputs which inputs so it can
take one sequence or multiple sequences
and if it takes multiple of them it'll
step over them in lockstep okay that's
one generalization another
generalization is that some of its
inputs don't have to the sequences and
they'll just be repeated those are the
constants that I mentioned in there
and the final generalization which is
actually less important than others is
that not all of the outputs have to be
returned as actual sequences that's a
lot to unpack I think I think the first
thing to focus on is the feedbacks so
when you think about net fold what do
you think about fold
what fold does is takes output and feeds
it back to the second argument of the
call of the function good this
generalizes that to take any set of the
outputs and feed them back to any input
positions in some well we've got
functions that do that so net so fold
pair yes among others right so among
other things this is a generalization of
fold pair two tuples
you
you
you
I okay so hold on okay let's break apart
the logic of this conversation so one
thing is is there a missing functional
programming operation that is now useful
for networks that could be supported for
lists but we don't happen to have it for
lists that's kind of what I'm aiming at
yes
it doesn't have to mirror Netra current
operator very much at all it just has to
be some way of getting this
functionality but I don't know what the
current operator does so I mean it it's
some kind of Foley like thing that
you've decided net fold operator isn't
enough for why not so one reason is that
there multiple of these recurrences
potentially so the second outputs fit
back to the second input and the third
outwards fit back to the third input and
you return the first output for example
how long can you okay this is the
principal parametrize these behaviors in
net fold operator so we don't introduce
a new function which is a new function
that's going to get thrown away
we could
I mean seems to me if we're going to
throw away both of them anyway we might
as well just changed net fold operator
and not and try to figure out the
generalization of the functional
programming thing which we can then use
when we don't have to have special net
star operators net star functions yeah
yeah that's a fair point okay I'll do
that um that does make things easier
actually
there's okay there's one thing to say
though which is that um another
difference is that fold operator does
not the it's more fold Lister operator
because actually true
returns the sequence of states so I'm
just highlighting the challenge that we
face here and trying to reconcile what
the new network world wants and what our
existing functional language constructs
do um this is a mess tally I mean look
so look in another in a in some amount
of time we will my guess is that first
point is it's not obvious to me okay you
know whether the functions that have
been primarily defined for lists see I
would like to see I would like to see a
version of the net for example that is
simply written in terms of our existing
functions right but you could certainly
do
I mean forget any of the by the way how
do I get out the specific the explicit
net chain from the met
what do you mean by that amid you want
the layers to say normal I think that
should work so if I do this
okay and then I say normal of this I
don't think that works but I'm wrong
okay all right so the challenge is to
take that and write the operation that
it performs with ordinary code right so
softmax layer for example there is
simply you know I mean that's just
saying use the softmax function which
correct
you know element wise right
no softmax is look I mean look at
softmax its this will not discuss this
it's on our agenda soon I think you
probably haven't approved this but maybe
I mentioned it and we defer this to
another time but anyway there is a
meeting about this it's in the
discussion on boss function but and this
is an example of something where there
was just genuinely a missing function
that this injunction that we have a
layer version oh yes okay well we need
to talk about that agenda
okay Sushil it was you were you aware of
that no I was done I mean it's part of
an upcoming meeting which is called loss
function so necklace meant me we're
going to discuss that one okay but the
softmax as a symbolic thing this looks
not anyway there's a typo there but but
what about soft max of X and soft max is
a vectorial operation that is defined
you say max that's pretty wild
okay unclear to me what that's doing in
terms of normalization
so just suffixes to just raise all of
its its its components to I mean they
exponentiated and then yeah okay listen
we need to talk about this function can
we make sure its first and they I mean
it's yeah we need to not mess this up
okay so
how would you write all of this I mean
the linear layers are just linear
algebra right sure these are the those
guys are not the ones that you'd want
they should remain layers so the things
that should be pure functions are things
that don't have any learn herbal
parameters in them those are the things
that are just ordinary programming you
know the things that have learn about
parameters are there other things that
deserve to stay in layers so convolution
so the net is a bad example in fact
because all of the the nets that we were
originally focusing on were mainly nets
that didn't have the property that they
were filled with these weightless
structural layers they were mostly
convolutions and so on all linear layers
ok and so that's why we didn't see as
the cutely
like where this whole thing was going so
with NLP with the tension basics knits
becomes much more common that you're
doing a lot more programming and a lot
less using of these heavy layers with
learned parameters and if that makes
sense yeah ok so I wouldn't look at I
wouldn't look at and look at that a good
example would be something like like a
transformer net which has got a lot of
kind of piping and interconnection and
sort of different stages and not quite
as many weights okay all right but
anyway this net recurrent operator thing
oh gosh
by the way is this really even right
doesn't this have the wrong number isn't
it a fencepost type thing this is the
wrong number of ins and outs
she pair them up like that I don't know
what you mean
the number of things if you've got an
input if you've got a first state and it
feeds out and out
oh maybe this is right then it feeds
into a single in yeah but at the end no
at the end there's an outfit comes out
with no corresponding in all the outs I
see what you're getting at
remember your you will net there can
have any number of inputs in any number
of outputs right some of the inputs come
from outside and they are mapped over
some of those inputs are fed via
recurrences and they're matched up to
particular outputs you know you you also
emit the sequence of states for those
outputs in addition to feeding them back
so there doesn't have to be a sort of
one-to-one there will be one left over
of inputs and that's what you mapped
over in the first place
I was the input sequence yeah it's a
question from the live stream about
about whether we could use tensor flow
yeah I'm principal I mean when
particularly with this onyx you know
for Matt I think it makes it much more
things we're doing more transportable is
that correct tally well certainly one of
the things with with yeah onyx will make
things more transportable in terms of
using a back-end we wouldn't want to go
through onyx to do that one of the
reasons we couldn't use tensorflow
at least in the beginning was that it
was kind of a lot of it was implemented
in Python and we don't want to have yet
another sort of dynamic language sitting
in between Mathematica and the actual
computations but I think tensorflow 2
might be better at that I'll need to
check up on that yeah early way and
those questions about glue on which I
thought was an MX net thing clone is a
pythons of kind of high-level wrapper
for mx8
okay there okay there's a question here
about the documentation pages would
benefit from more simple practical
examples in applications of properties
in relations I'm sure that's true
current there's no transformer nets in
the documentation yet transformers
require all kinds of features been
working hard at for version 12 and they
are possible in 12 and we will have some
nice language model modeling transformer
nets in neural net repository hopefully
simultaneous with the release of 12 okay
all right okay throwing one of the
things that was very important for
transfer minutes was generalizing our
attention layer quite considerably and
it's very powerful now I was just
working on on that today actually and
yeah that makes it very nice to build
transformer nets it's very simple
so is this another thing we have to
review we've already reviews reviewed
this I mean we can always go look at it
again if you want okay let's go back to
net recurrent operator okay
okay what are the changes that you're
trying to do here relative to that fold
operator so we're generalizing the
number of recurrences that can can be
beyond one we're generalizing the number
of inputs you can have beyond one and we
also generalizing a number of outputs
they can be beyond one and some of the
inputs can be constant which is very
important okay so the creature
eventually has four legs
so in this feedback you are saying
folded over
what the heck
I'm not understanding this I mean that
list there is knitting together certain
outputs and certain inputs correct yes I
mean a diagram would be worth a thousand
words but don't have one of those yet
um
okay
but I'm sorry each each one of these are
you commissioning getting a diagram
produced by the way here and we are so
overloaded trying to finish everything
up for
sketch 1 and ask somebody and design to
make it okay now that's that's can't con
objected that um okay so I'm still
trying to understand here you've got
this list out goes to n etc right yeah
I I'm sorry I'm really confused what's
happening I mean can you give me an
analogy with that with a like some kind
of thing could we imagine a recurrence
here over an association for example
with a bunch of ports defined by an
association does that make any sense or
is that something completely different
um it may may be you can scroll down I
think the first example might illustrate
things nicely um that's the core that
we're gonna put into that recurrent
operator okay all the fold operator for
the free just make that better you see
it's got two inputs and let's go on
output and that second argument I've
given there in the third input line
we're actually build the recurrent
operator I've got the line the
recurrence output arrow stage you see
that they also see that so what that's
saying is that this call is going to be
repeated this block will be repeated
again and again and outputs the output
output will be fed back to provide the
value of the next state for the next
block okay okay how are these times will
this be done how many times is it
folding
what is it folding over well that see
that leaves one leg left over which is
the complicity operator I see and that's
yes exactly
yeah so whatever is left over can walk
along sequences if there's one leg it'll
walk along one sequence if they're
multiple legs then they can how many how
does it get multiple legs
well that cool that I defined there
Chris had three inputs the I see what
you say okay so how does it know
I say they have to be named inputs but
how does it know
oh boy what does input varying comma two
mean and that means that the input to
the entire operator is a matrix you know
my garden on Rose this is pretty hockey
you
well I mean look at this stage and at
this point in the recycle we're not
getting any better than this I suggest
you just clean up the thing not talk
about fold all over the place and make
it experimental should we but should we
bundle it into fold operator thank you
where is knee saying that might be as he
said might be better because then we we
kind of cauterizing a design we may not
like long term into something that's
gonna be retired anyway if you're sure
it's going to be retired yes I mean the
challenge still remains and I think
you're right it's we can't do this now
challenge is to define the core language
function that is how you would Express
this recurrence without making use of
operators at all I think yes right well
it's not unless what it is is is
no I don't know totally would be it
would be something like fold pair
merciful careless to whatever yes it's a
it's a thing that takes I mean where as
fold pair
expects just so we thought about fold
how general fold pair can be okay
because fall pair is like like kind of a
transducer that goes down the list at
every point both emitting and feeding
something on to the next step okay
yes and I don't think I think that is as
general as it can be I don't think
there's a more general version of that
is there are you are you claiming that
your thing as a more general version I
am
so it generalizes because the pair can
be a couple where you emitting in your
pair case you're emitting the first
piece and you're feeding back the second
piece yes but in my in my recurrent
operator the output of that net is a
tuple of any length and you feeding back
arbitrary pieces to arbitrary slots in
the next cycle and you're missing
arbitrary other pieces that's right I
think that's not generalized a
generalization it's just that there are
some you know filtering functions on
both sides of that it's the same thing I
mean you've got you know the question of
whether you have you know whether you're
pre-filtering that you're you know
you're omitting a couple okay great
there's a single expression which
couldn't itself be a list for instance
obviously okay so you saying it's piping
so modulo some piping it's the same
thing that's what I'm saying yes yeah I
agree but I mean full pair list is
different from fold list yes and and
actually the other awkwardness is that
fold list and fold pair list
I think they returned the original
initial value unchanged which is like
it's not what any network does because
yeah I understand
the identity is not hasn't learned to do
anything useful
this is immense the design challenge
I mean now I know I know but it's not
one that we can you know solve properly
at this stage
what's a very qualified name for net
recurrent operator the longest
reasonable name we could give it well by
analogy with maps read and it is very
similar to how we took net map operates
that we made net map thread operator we
couldn't have net fold thread operator
because its operating on multiple input
sequences simultaneously and doing other
crazy stuff it seems reasonable to me
that seems reasonable to me I mean I
mean the disadvantage of that is that
sprawled thread might be a genuinely
interesting language thing of its own
right but maybe not I don't know that's
a good question um but how general is
net recurrent operator I mean will it
will it show up all the time or is it is
it an obscure corner case um these
features do a show to show up so like we
need them for transformers that's why we
can't punt on this transformers ism yeah
they're very important um I honestly
think the best thing would be to put all
this Internet fold operate as you
suggested originally
alright alright alright fine try and do
it um we've got some questions here is
onyx going to be an export format yes
the answer is yes right not twelve there
but soon soon and we've got this brought
up whatever they call protobuf things
protocol buffers yeah right
which were provided for onyx that was a
prerequisite so that functionality is
there yeah questioned apparently came up
on Stack Exchange today why is there no
net decoder of quotes function there is
actually I that's been a Edyta fault
oh it's been added for 12 okay okay
someone's asking what's the net
recurrent operator and things like PI
torch obviously I don't have a clue
so there's answer to this question which
is that other frameworks and onyx have
exactly this thing and it's called scan
so tensorflow uses this term on excuses
that term and basically net recurrent
operator is what's can be okay be not no
certainly not
um okay Sebastian are you happy with
blue folding this internet fold operator
I'm not sure about it so I do you think
that that's okay so what I like about it
so first of all I think it's in the long
run we will have this unless it becomes
some language primitive well which it
will which is what we've been discussing
during the time you weren't here yeah a
part of that so if it does become a
language primitive than it doesn't
really matter too much because we'd
retire either form I guess so
yeah why not just use the count operator
at fault I think so I mean it's not
wonderful but um and I mean then
exercise of thinking through folding the
tea folding business again we did spend
some amount of time thinking about this
in connection with fold pair
and vocalist um
I am yes I really do think up - up -
piping
yeah it does do the have this
functionality maybe there's some sugar
that we could add full piping so all it
could even be that fold pair could have
some Association type behavior that's
currently meaningless and I was thinking
of something like that right where the
pilot one yes all right look I think we
need a separate discussion about with
other people about the functional
programming aspects of these kinds of
operators but for now let's kind of hack
it internet fold operator all right
everything else we need here on earth is
this oh great
alright how is the rest of the norm that
stuff coming together for the for the
twelve oh I don't think Friday isn't
realistic
oh well I'm sorry but it has to be so
what what is what's the problem there's
just too many balls in the air that's
aren't gonna all land by Friday but I
think another another week will be
enough I know it's not probably the
right combination it's not it's not
going to happen I mean actually it's
been it's beyond Friday you're gonna get
into a Monday evening
and then you know
time than that you got it you got to
commit what you can commit and then
we'll have to just treat those things as
bug fixes
but try hard to get the thing in by the
actual free state because every other
component of hundreds of components are
ready so please don't be the last
component
in fact I know of no other components
that in fact sushma do you know of
anything else that I mean as of as of
earlier today we were being told to go
ahead say no I mean been discussed today
I think no one really objected off
Mondays free state so you know it
reminds me tally there was a company
that I was once agreed to be on the
board of at least for a while
where the person the CEO of the company
would have these meetings scheduled for
an hour or whatever and they would all
be oh we're doing this and we're doing
this we're doing this and then in the
last couple of minutes of the meeting
he'd say oh and by the way we're gonna
run out of money in two weeks that's
some well you know okay so yes send a
little bit of a little bit of kind of
letting off letting off steam time on
the weekend this is actually on Sunday
um I did some experimentation with
reinforcement learning do you want to
see a very quick 30 seconds the
screenshare yes all right this is you
know tally in the you know it's I love
the way there's a you know there's this
big freeze for a big version coming
right and so what does tally doing extra
time he does something which isn't going
to make it into that version but is it
actually actually is the one of the
things the reason soap and I've worked
on this on the weekend is if we wanted
to make sure that if there was any kind
of bugs in the framework or all right
okay let's let's see the demo okay here
you can share sure I so just for context
this is a little task that I defined
which is an orbit so it's little orbital
simulation of like loading a rocket and
the rocket can choose to fire in one of
four directions to move around right but
it's subject to gravity and the task
I've given it is to specify that how did
you specify that that set up
um I made a device so just I cooked into
Sebastien's you know similar some
external at some pseudo external device
yeah exactly so it actually looks like
it's good simulated spaceship and this
is not an official this is on a branch
but we could ship it if you know who
cleaned it up a bit anyway so I gave it
gravity and so on and if you if you just
make agents then you can you can this
agent has got a constant action avoids
going left and it'll just shoot off to
the right in fact if I give it a random
action of any action between 1 and 5
then Oh random integer not random choice
then it'll just kind of blog around the
place going right going after time and
the color shows what action it took and
the size of the dot shows the reward it
got so I'm rewarding things for being
close to the center of the gravity well
and that its job should obviously be to
figure out how to go live at the bottom
of this gravity well that's that's what
we want to reward now the fun thing is
it turns out it's not very much work to
have simple reinforcement orgrim
reinforcement learning algorithms
expressed in the framework and better
than that you can visualize the
solutions while training happens so I'm
using the kind of ancient algorithm
called reinforce which doesn't converge
very quickly that it does work and by
keeping the random seeds the same I can
visualize you know however many
different trajectories as training
progresses how it would do things
differently on those particular examples
and we can see it hopefully Bend all of
these in so that the rocket has
eventually a kind of dwelling near the
center of the gravity rule which I think
it's fun ok but so the reinforced loss
can I see the definition of that sure
it's
it's literally just multiplying the
cross-entropy
of what the and it chose to do with the
reward
by the way one of the other design
meetings we have is why you would
express this with loss function
improvements to loss function to make it
easy to go write this kind of thing so
instead of using a graph it would look
much much simpler than this but you
simply look like cross entropy of the
output of the net first as the action it
took prongs by the reward and that just
becomes its system it's actually simpler
than that it's crashing it so it looks
like that which i think is much more
readable than the state graph over here
who knows what that does yes
well that's nice well this is cool okay
so the things gonna learn how to fall
into a black hole or something right
very nice very nice all right okay that
was an attempt to recover from the fact
that you just sort of announce that
you're not gonna be ready for this
freeze date but you really have to get
as much as you can ready yep okay all
right well see you guys soon people who
are on the live stream we are about to
go to another meeting um also that will
be live-streamed so hope to see you
there
alright see you later thanks